Today I'm speaking to 21 year old
Neelakantha Bhanu, who won the gold medal for
India at the 2020 Mind Sports Olympiad, and he
holds a few world records for being the world's
fastest human calculator.
Toby: I think we first got in contact with each other
after I made a video about Shakuntala Devi, from
India, and she previously I think, held this
record for you know, Fastest Human Calculator.
And yeah, I'm wondering, have you beaten her
record? And if so, what was that record?
Bhanu: Shakuntala Devi was, let's say, one of the
first mathemagicians if I have to put it this way,
who has established math as a performance act,
which is that going out on stages, making people
clap, making people enjoy the art of, let's say,
solving questions in front of them.
She held a lot of world records.
But there's this one specific world record,
which is called the Fastest Human Calculator record,
where one gets to add a number to itself as quickly as possible.
If it's a two digit number, if I have to put it this way,
one has to do the multiples of it very quickly, and say the answers out.
So if I start with 28,
it goes 28, 56, 84, 112, 140, 168, and so on, so on.
So the record is to do as many times in 15 seconds.
So these records were once held by her, Mr. Scott
Flansburgh from the United States, and that's the
record which I've broken a couple of years ago, in
racing past and doing it for 42 times in 15 seconds.
I've seen some videos of it done, and yeah, I find it really impressive.
And in fact, when I first read the story of Shakuntala,
and then heard your story as well,
My initial thoughts, and maybe these are the thoughts
of many people, it's like; wow, that is such a
special talent. And those people seem so different
to me.
Because, you know, I feel like I could never do
that and I think many people maybe feel the same.
I wonder if you could answer you know, is there
something special about you guys who can do this?
Bhanu: I personally do not think that this is a
feat or a feature which can be achieved by being
gifted, or being let's say naturally innately
talented. Because of one sure reason that
everyone's born with the same, let's say
mathematical, what do we say? raw materials?
It’s just about how you train it. And my question
again, which again, I think I'll do more as we go,
which is to compare it, compare math with being
sport is that if one wants a ripped body with a
tight six pack, is it really possible for
everyone? Yes. But it does take the effort, which
is to train, to diet, do a bunch of stuff.
Toby: Yeah. So it sounds like you're saying it
takes, you know, the willingness and the
motivation to want to do this, and also a lot of
hard work. Yeah, I guess training like any classic
olympian for for any other sport, I guess. So you
know, I'd be curious to know, when you were
training for this, what was your sort of daily
routine? How did you find the time to do this kind
of study?
Bhanu: So I mean, my journey in mental calculation
started when I was very young, very, very young.
So I actually met with an accident when I was
five, when I was bedridden for an entire year.
That has nothing to do with my calculation
abilities. But at that point of time, I picked up
puzzles and calculations as a way which is, be it
magic squares, be it a bunch of other stuff, which
we genuinely, let's say, see in our daily routine,
right? So I mean, this was the point of time where
I sort of picked and started falling in love with
what puzzles and math and numbers and stuff are. I
fumbled on to, let's say, taking mental
calculation as something which I was interested in
and started going for regional championships, and
I won the regionals, nationals and the
international championships in the span of three
years. Directly, I was the international champion
in speed calculation under the age of 20 years, by
the time I was 13. That was in Singapore. My
routine when I did practice for this was I used to
go to school, come back around 4pm in the evening,
and then sort of work because I mean, at the end
of the day, I would consider mental math to be a
sport, which again, gives it a value of
entertainment, right? So I mean, for me, it never
was that; okay, sit in front of the paper, solve
this exam. It was about give this attempt, try
doing this better, play better. So it's the kind
of satisfaction or the sense of achievement you
get when you get your soccer balls swing in the
air and that's pretty much what what drove me
forward. I used to practice around six to seven
hours a day, consistently for three to four years.
Today, I don't practice as much, but I still make
it a point that I'm active for at least one, one
and a half hour every day to sort of look into
this and pursue this further. Because I think this
has answers to a lot of things which human
cognition has to scope in and do more in.
Toby: Great, yeah, one thing I'd be curious to ask
is that, you know, on my channel, I've done a few
videos in the past relating to exams and
specifically exams in India, things like the JEE
to get into university. And before we were
recording, you said that you've gone on to study
maths at university. So clearly, you know, at the
same time you were studying for this, you know,
mental maths, you were also studying your normal
schoolwork, right? And did you ever sit the JEE
and have to do exams at the same time? How was
that, balancing them?
Bhanu: I really did well in my JEE. In fact, I
actually scored a 115/120 in my JEE in math. So
again right, I would look at it in two directions,
which is mathematical acumen building can happen
from any side. It's about, I personally look at
this as a mountain, you can climb it from any
forte, but the end is mathematical excellence. And
there's no way you miss out on things as you
climb. So I mean, for instance, if I am doing a
speed calculation and at some point of time I
wanted to do an approximation, there is no way I
can do that without knowing the Taylor series,
there is no way I can do that without knowing how
do I extrapolate and sort of do a bunch of other
things. When I'm, let's say, approximating a few
calculations there's a lot of ideologies which go
behind it, be it, let's say conic sections, be it
a lot of other stuff, which I think is a part of
what we do, number theory majorly. So, prime
factorization, if that's the calculation I'm going
for. I learned a lot of formal math, through the
problems I faced while I scaled on becoming the
world's fastest human calculator. So I will say
that my journey in math was intertwined.
Toby: I really liked the comment that you made a
bit before about kind of what you had learned
about the human brain and about learning itself
through your experiences. And I wonder if you
could talk maybe a little bit more about that,
because maybe that kind of gives a usefulness as
well to what you're doing. Not that it, you know,
needs a usefulness because I know many sports you
do just for the sake of showing what's possible,
but it seems like here, the mental calculation
stuff can kind of reveal a bit more about how we
work, how we think.
Bhanu: Noam Chomsky, a very famous linguist says
that you sort of look at the world, the way you
learn language, which is watching the world
through the language glass, which is one of the
most revolutionary works between language and cognition.
I personally think that language and the way you
learn numbers sort of determine how you look at
the world in general. And if I have to put it this
way, from research which has been done by Piaget,
or a lot of other mathematician-philosophers have
worked on this, or mathematical psychologists,
it's observed more so now than ever, that the way
some kid or a student learns the number system,
the way they learn the operations of math, the way
they learn how naturally one flows from the other
logical argumentation and stuff sort of determines
their cognitive compass. If I have to say this
that way. When I say cognitive compass, I'm
talking about the working memory, the iterative
memory, the long term memory, the reflex, the
ability to partition thought, the ability to
parallel think, a lot of things here, and if I
have to compare it with let's say, computers, or
let's say how a computer functions, it's about how
you develop your RAM. How you develop your your
GPU, how you develop your processor, however that
goes.
Toby: Yeah, I guess on that, and also bringing
back the, you know, parallels to sports, why do
you think that you are able to beat for example,
Shakuntala's record? And I asked that because, you
know, in sports, in some sports, maybe marathon
running or something else, you see that over time,
people seem to be getting faster. Maybe it's the
shoes or the swimsuits they're wearing or maybe
it's the way we train. But do you think in a
similar way that people are getting smarter? Is
that why records are being broken here?
Bhanu: Sure, I could probably do that. Because I
mean, I personally think my practice majorly has
not been through pen and paper solutions. It has
been aided by software a lot. And I would say that
that's something which, I think plays a very key
role. It's this way, right? I mean, there's two
ways to approach let's say, running for that same
marathon, which is, one is to keep running for
that 100 metres expecting growth, or do 10k runs,
do runs with weight, do runs with something else,
train yourself in 10 different things. So that
eventually when you come back to this, you are
better. Mental calculation, and the art of it is
slowly in decline, which is, I mean, when I look
forward, when I when I talk to let's say 60 year
old war veterans, 70 year old World War veterans
across the globe, or, I mean, whenever I go and
talk, they're way quicker at what they do than
let's say, people of my age, or under because of
the reliance on calculators a lot, which is great.
For instance, I mean, no one really wants to
calculate cost 46 and a half. We don't really want
to do that, because there's machines doing it for
us. So when I compare it to the sport, this is
exactly what I say. And I think I'll probably
repeat it here, which establishes the point. Usain
Bolt runs for 100 metres, right. The reason he
runs for the 100 metres is to make sure to inspire
people to say that, okay, see, this is what being
fit is. It's not that he does not have a car. So
it's not that he does not have a car. So I would
probably end up with that saying that, if you
today, if you're here, you should probably be
using Wolfram Alpha. If you're here, you should be
using your MATLAB and Mathematica. If you're not,
you're not in the math game. But at the same time,
it's extremely important for you to train your
brain. And there's no better exercise than
counting. And trust me. That's literally what I
put here. Brain exercise is, I personally think
that math, if you lose out on calculations to be a
way in which you train yourself, you're sort of
missing out one part of the jigsaw puzzle.
Toby: It's really interesting to hear that perhaps
technology has played a role in helping you to
break records.
I guess I'd love to hear a little bit more about
you know, what you're doing now, your current
mission?
Bhanu: Math failure is one of the major reasons
why students drop out of school, which is to drop
out of any other educational trajectory they can
have. So I think the problem which I do go on, and
I probably wish to solve is sort of at least make
math not the speed breaker for someone's career
opportunity, because it doesn't, it shouldn't be
that hard. And if you let's say inspire people,
because I think that the problem is twofold; one
is that it's the social perception that math is
boring, which I think it's existent regardless of
the country I'm talking about 'oh not math, not
really, not my thing'.
'Oh, you do math, you're a geek'.
So I'm trying to change that by let's say, doing
performances and stage shows across the globe.
Toby: This, the competitive side of, you know,
human calculation, it will really help some people
to get inspired with maths. For some people, that
won't be quite right, because it might bring that,
you know, the sense of pressure and
competitiveness that comes along with exams, too.
It can it can actually sometimes be detrimental.
So I think one approach will not work for
everyone. This has clearly worked for you and,
yeah, I would like to add a little disclaimer
that, you know, I personally studied math at uni
as well. And I found that yeah, you can get by
just fine without being good at arithmetic, and
it's not really going to hold you back. But it's
interesting to hear your story of a case where
it's actually really helped propel you forward.
Bhanu: Math phobia exists, I mean, let's accept
it, that there is a scare of every math exam,
which comes your way. The two ways to go about it.
One is to, as you said, I mean, I think as you
pointed out also, that competitively getting it
overwith is not always the best way to go about
it. Also, because of the fact that if you really
want to write a book, you don't really have to be
a spell bee champion. It's as simple as that. But
both of them have their own beautiful forms and I
believe that moving forward  we have more people
who sort of work towards catering such experiences
globally, where kids no longer are scared of math,
but are accepted. They accept it as, let's say, a
part of their life just as we do with English or
any other native language you speak.
Toby: Great. Yeah, it's a big mission, but I think
it's a good one. Yeah, one little question I'd
like to end with is do you have maybe a role model
or someone that you really look up to maybe from
history or now?
Bhanu: Actually a lot of mathematicians, but let
me restrict to a couple of them. One very, very
major inspiration through my life from the
beginning, how much ever I understood him or not,
from the beginning was Srinivasa Ramanujan, from
India. And, I mean, I would say that my devotion
towards his work is, is I think, goes a long way
because of the fact that, okay, one is obviously
the cultural, the sort of Indian-ness and the
promotion of what he has done globally. But the
sheer nature of let's say, every time I look up
into, let's say, read more, I realise that oh,
this is more apt to what I do. So I mean, wherever
I was fumbling across a bunch of things, I've
somehow always come to a certain paper of his
which I'm like, oh, wow, this, I think is
applicable to what I do. So I will say that he was
one of my major inspirations.
Around, let's say, performances and making math a
culture or let's say something which people
consume in India, I'm thankful for Shakuntala
Devi. She was never a formal mathematics person
herself. She was never formally trained. But I
think the relatability of a mathematician to an
average citizen of a country is I think, something
which, which I think I've learned a lot from.
Toby: Great. Well, yeah, I find both of those
people also very inspirational. So, yeah,
Bhanu: I mean, nameless to say the other couple of
people include Laplace and Newton. I mean, I've
not gone there. But yeah, but I've not gone there
now. Yeah.
Toby: Some of the greats. Yeah. All right. Well,
congratulations on all of your success. And thanks
for sharing your insights.
Bhanu: Thank you. Thanks a lot. It was nice, nice
being here.